zeitreisen in die vergangenheit ein
großer traum von vielen und doch
unmöglich oder etwa doch nicht nach
unserem allgemeinen zeitverständnis
bewegt sich die zeit immer nur in eine
richtung die zukunft alles ist auf sie
ausgerichtet ein internationales
forschungsteam will jetzt aber in einem
experiment zeigen dass spezielle
quantensystem mit tatsächlich in der
lage sind in der zeit zurückzureisen und
das sogar ohne die gängigen gesetze der
physik zu verletzen wie genau das
funktionieren soll und was wirklich dran
ist jetzt in klicks um science-fiction
nur hier gibt es täglich faszinierende
wissenschafts videos abonniert den kanal
nur dann verpasst er nichts los geht's
[Musik]
wenn man mal genauer auf derzeit herum
denkt merkt man mit der zeit dass es nur
einen statistischen grund gibt dass sie
zeit sich nur in eine richtung bewegen
kann denn mathematische und
physikalische gesehen würde derzeit fall
genauso gelten wenn sich die objekte
rückwärts durch die zeit bewegen im
alltag kennen wir nur das bild eines
wasserglas das kaputt geht weil es auf
dem boden fällt und dort in tausend
scherben zerbricht die gesetze der
mechanik hätten allerdings nichts
dagegen wenn die scherben sich in der
luft zusammen setzen würden und das glas
letztendlich wieder ganz auf dem tisch
stehen würde
im alltag natürlich undenkbar denn
dagegen spricht die entropie das maß der
unordnung demnach ist die
wahrscheinlichkeit für unordnung
deutlich höher als verordnung denn es
gibt für ein system einfach deutlich
mehr möglichkeiten ungeordnet zu sein
als geordnet zu sein ein kaputtes glas
entspricht in unserem beispiel der
unordnung ein ganzes glas dagegen der
ordnung und mit der zeit nimmt das maß
an unordnung zu
das entspricht dem zweiten hauptsatz der
thermodynamik und deswegen ist es immer
statistisch wahrscheinlicher dass
unordnung entsteht als ordnung und durch
diesen weg in die unordnung wird derzeit
fall bestimmt wird etwas ordentlicher
werden und damit die entropie geringer
wäre die zeit nach den regeln der
thermodynamik umgedreht es wäre eine
reise in die vergangenheit jetzt kommen
wir zu unserem experiment in dem es auch
um die entropie geht genauer gesagt um
einen speziellen aspekt dabei der
wärmeleitung auch dazu wieder ein
beispiel wenn man zwei körper
zusammenbringt die eine unterschiedliche
temperatur haben gleicht sich die
so aus die wärme fließt vom wärmen
objekt zum kälteren bis die temperatur
in etwa gleich ist bezogen auf die
entropie ist das damit zu erklären dass
es einfach viel mehr zustände gibt in
denen die einzelnen teilchen der beiden
körper dieselbe energie haben
unvorstellbar dagegen der zustand dass
keine wärme fließt oder aber der wärmere
körper noch wärmer wird und der kältere
noch kälter doch genau solch ein
quantensystem hat das internationale
forschungsteam jetzt in einem experiment
konstruiert konkret ging es um ein
chloroform molekül bei dem ein kaltes
atom wärmeabgabe und zwar ein anderes
atom das eigentlich wärmer war
damit wurde der zeit fall umgekehrt es
passierte etwas das nur passieren kann
wenn die zeit rückwärts läuft so das
forschungsteam und das ohne die gesetze
der thermodynamik zu verletzen
denn es war eine quanten korrelation
zwischen den atomen ins spiel
und dies sei eine eigene form von
ordnung so die beteiligten
wissenschaftlerinnen und wissenschaftler
und die mache es möglich wärme rückwärts
fließen zu lassen quasi eine art
treibstoff die gesetze der thermodynamik
aber geld nur für und korrelierte
systeme dazu der koautor der studie eric
lux von der universität erlangen
nürnberg
das ergebnis zeigt dass der pfeil
derzeit kein absolutes konzept sondern
ein relatives konzept ist doch ist
dieses experiment tatsächlich der
nachweis dafür dass ein quantensystem in
die vergangenheit reisen kann eine
wissenschaftliche prüfung jedenfalls ist
noch nicht geschehen denn die studie
wurde bislang noch nicht in einer
fachzeitschrift veröffentlicht die nach
dem sogenannten peer review prozess
arbeitet dabei beleuchten unabhängige
wissenschaftlerinnen und wissenschaftler
studien sehr genau aber immerhin wurde
darüber schon in spektrum berichtet ein
erster ritterschlag bin mal gespannt ob
sich das wirklich bestätigt denn
eigentlich spricht physikalisch nichts
gegen zeitreise in die vergangenheit
naja vielleicht das chaos und die
paradoxien die dann entstehen würden
auch ein paradoxon dass fermi paradoxon
erste antworten von raum zeit lockt der
zukunft super video unbedingt drauf
kriegen falls das noch nicht gesehen
habt also auf jeden fall machen bis dann
bleib dran